[Music]
on this Tuesday night Donald Trump loses
a major legal battle a top US court
rules he is not immune from prosecution
no one is above the law the reasons his
response and his next legal
hurdles King Charles seen for the first
time since his cancer diagnosis is it a
moment to reconcile with his youngest
son plus questions about his planned
visit to
Canada dreading a disastrous Deja why a
northern Canadian Town fears another
ferocious Wildfire
season plus he was rebellious revered
and red white and blue you give me a
great idea and I'll write you a great
song tributes to country music giant
Toby
ke global national with Donna FZ good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with a Court ruling in the US
which found former American president
Donald Trump can be put on trial for
attempting to stay in power after losing
the 2020 presidential election the three
judges on the federal appeals court
wrote we cannot accept former president
Trump's claim that a president has
unbounded authority to commit crimes
that would neutralize the most
fundamental check on executive power it
means Trump is not above the law though
he intends to appeal claiming immunity
is a must Trump is the first former US
president to face criminal charges there
are four separate ongoing cases in our
top story tonight Jackson prco looks at
whether this decision brings him closer
to a
trial our country has had enough we will
not take it anymore never had a sitting
president so brazenly defied the will of
Voters we will never give up we will
never concede more than 3 years later an
appeals court ruled Donald Trump can be
prosecuted for his alleged attempts to
overturn the election he lost from his
actions in the White House to the
January 6th attack on the US
capital a president has to have immunity
and the other thing is I did nothing
wrong though Trump continues to claim he
and all other presidents cannot be
prosecuted a three-judge panel disagreed
ruling any executive immunity that may
have protected him while he served as
president no longer protects him against
this
prosecution legally speaking the former
president is now just an ordinary
citizen it's really important legally
it's really important procedurally it
is uh a reaffirmation in this country no
one is above the law in August special
counsel Jack Smith indicted Trump on
charges of conspiracy and obstruction
for alleged election subversion Trump's
immunity appeal put the trial on hold in
its scathing opinion the appeals court
weighed in on the charges arguing Trump
allegedly injected himself into a
process in which the president has no
role they added if upheld Trump's
immunity argument would collapse our
system of separated Powers by placing
the president beyond the reach of all
three branches the court said that look
yes presidents need to be given
discretion to execute their
constitutional duties but that
discretion does not extend to violating
federal law Trump has already vowed to
appeal to the Supreme Court he must do
so by Monday whether the high court
makes up the case will determine whether
a trial about the last election will
take place before the next one and
Jackson is with me now Jackson the US
Supreme Court is set to rule on another
question about Trump that could affect
his ability to run for president again
tell us about that one that's right
Donna on Thursday the court will hear
arguments in the Colorado ballot case
that state pulled Trump off the ballots
arguing that he is ineligible for office
because he committed an Insurrection the
case is being watched closely by other
states and could have an impact on
whether Trump remains on the ballot in
several other states and Donna it's an
urgent matter because Colorado's primary
is coming up in early March Jackson
prosco in Washington tonight thanks and
here's a sign of what it's like to run
for office in the US Nikki Haley Donald
Trump's only rival for the Republican
Presidential nomination has applied for
protection from the US Secret Service
her campaign says she has faced multiple
threats though they didn't reveal
specifics the home of the former US
ambassador to the UN has been targeted
in two swatting incidents in the past
two months Homeland Security will now do
a threat assessment and decide if she
will get secret service Protection
security at the US Mexico border is a
big part of a $118 billion bipartisan
immigration bill in the US that appears
to be falling apart today President Joe
Biden urged Congress to pass it and
blame Donald Trump for being behind the
effort to kill it now all indications
are that this bill won't even move
forward to the senate floor why a simple
reason Donald Trump because Donald Trump
thinks it's bad for him politically
Biden is urging Congress to show some
spine and stand up to Trump trump has
been pushing Congressional leaders to
reject the deal which ties border
changes to aid for Ukraine and Israel
Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
vows the Democrats will keep at
it Prince Harry has flown from
California to London to see his dad King
Charles less than 24 hours after it was
revealed the King has cancer Harry was
seen arriving at clarence's house the
king's residence in London it's believed
Harry hadn't seen his father since the
king's coronation last May King Charles
has already begun cancer treatment he
stepped back from public duties and
Royal Watchers wonder if Harry's visit
is a sign of a private reconciliation
between Father and Son Redmond Shannon
reports the first glimpse of the king
since he started cancer treatment
Charles and Camila heading from
clarence's house to Buckingham Palace
before flying off to Sandringham estate
almost nothing is known about the type
of cancer the King has but an optimistic
Insight came from prime minister Rishi
sunak speaking with the BBC shocked and
sad and just all our thoughts are with
him and his family and you know
thankfully this has been caught early
despite the early diagnosis Prince Harry
spared no time in getting to London from
California a meeting with a father he's
barely seen in recent years his whole
family feud things seems a bit silly in
my opinion but she'll make up and
hopefully this brings him together a
little bit more I don't know how much
things will change you know people are
talking about well this is the the
Breakthrough we don't know but illness
has a way of just putting everything in
perspective and I think that's what this
is Harry and Megan's departure from
Royal Life part of a dwindling roster of
senior Royals the desra raced prince
Andrew also stepping aside before the
deaths of Prince Phillip and Queen
Elizabeth and now serious health issues
for the Princess of Wales recovering
from abdominal surgery and for the King
Charles and Camila's reported plans to
visit Canada in the spring now up in the
air I think it's very difficult to
predict um where the royal family will
be in May and how busy a schedule they
will have particularly in terms of
overseas these tours we certainly have
seen in the past uh Royal travel
Arrangements being adjusted in various
ways in the event of um Health crisis
the ever busy Princess Anne and her
brother Prince Edward May pick up some
of the slack if they can find the time
there is no sense of when the king will
return to public duties but what we do
know is that his son Prince William will
return to public life on Wednesday
having taken a break while his wife
Katherine the princess of w
recovers from her surgery Donna Redmond
Shannon outside Buckingham Palace thanks
Redmond large parts of Southern
California remain under flood warnings
and there is a rare tornado warning for
San Diego at least three deaths have now
been linked to that record-breaking rain
there's a state of emergency in at least
eight counties in California hundreds of
mudslides have been reported in the Los
Angeles area since Sunday downtown LA
has been inundated with 6 months worth
of rain RF fall in Atlantic Canada tens
of thousands of people are still digging
their way out of some of the heaviest
snowfall in decades up to 1 meter has
fallen from Central Prince Edward Island
to Halifax and north towards Cape Breton
where there is so much snow a local
state of emergency is still in place as
Heidi petrac reports some rural
communities warn it could be days before
the roads are
cleared the cleanup will be a long one
my car was completely buried like
two hours ago so we're making progress
about 60 cm fell in the charlot town
area walls of snow Heming in some
secondary roads it's like driving
through a
tunnel the storm dumped an
estimated 15 cm on Sydney as it brought
all of Cape Bretton to a halt prompting
people like Henry OBU to lend a hand we
just need more more hands more hands on
deck the cap Breton Regional
municipality declared a local state of
emergency Sunday in an effort to get
Federal and provincial assistance the
mayor has a list of at least 200 people
who need help digging out it's been a
really rough few days uh people are
worried Panic is setting in because
there are people that are isolated um
they can't get out of their houses about
45 kilometers from Sydney the escon
First Nation also declared a state of
emergency for the same reason we're
getting a lot of call from EHS getting
people to dialysis for emergency we're
having issues with that the federal and
Nova Scotia governments have pledged to
send extra heavy equipment to Cape
Breton and Ottawa is also offering air
support to deliver supplies as the big
cleanup continues criticism has been
piled on top of Nova scotia's Premier
after Tim Houston questioned the cape
Britton regional municipality's state of
emergency declaration what a state of
emergency does not do is get you a plow
faster was it uh more of just a kind of
a PR PR issu is kind of what what I'm
wondering I'm hoping it was simply a
slip of the tongue the premier has since
apologized for his remarks calling them
quote a poor choice of words political
dust up aside officials are asking for
patience even with snow melters like
this digging out and cleaning up will
take days Heidi pic Global News
Halifax 2023 was the worst Wildfire
season on record in Canada and the
Northwest Territories was devastated
nearly 70% of the population was
displaced as fires burned across 4
million hectares last summer Melissa
riggen explains why people there are
looking for answers and accountability
ahead of what they fear could be an even
worse Wildfire season this year the
terror is still fresh the only Highway
out was on fire so it was completely
engulfed in flames Elena Katz and her
husband loaded up their alpacas and
cattle dogs last August as the Wood
Buffalo fire threatened their home in
Fort Smith they race towards Hay River
as directed but within hours of arriving
at what was supposed to be a safe haven
Hay River was evacuated to Alberta
through Enterprise the only Highway out
already Ablaze our truck caught
fire and my husband and I got out with
just what we were wearing we couldn't
save our
animals
um and we're live because somebody
stopped on the high way and um rescued
us nearly 90% of Enterprise leveled it's
an absolute miracle that there was no
loss of human life more than 20,000
people were forced to evacuate last
summer scattered in neighboring
provinces for a month when they returned
in September they wanted answers and
accountability over the fire management
communication with the public and the
handling of the evacuations cats and
1100 others including Municipal and
Indigenous leaders have signed a
petition demanding a public inquiry also
I think an opportunity for the
territorial government to restore public
confidence in the government newly
elected Premier RJ Simpson was himself
in evacuee these were traumatic events
and so we are conducting a third party
reviews independent third party reviews
of the response to the force fires as
well as um the evacuations how those
were handled and those are going to be
made public but for territory residents
the worry is when and without being
involved in the process can can their
trust in government be restored with the
2024 Wildfire season just around the
corner Melissa Ren Global News
Winnipeg concerns are also being raised
over how one fire was managed by Parks
Canada you can find out why on our
website global news.ca global national
police in BC say a man has been arrested
in Nigeria in a tragic case of teenage
sextortion 14-year-old Robin janua from
sui was contacted online last February
by someone posing as a teenage girl he
shared some intimate images then the
person demanded he send money in the
form of gift cards a short time later he
died by Suicide an international
investigation LED police to Legos
Nigeria where a 26-year-old man is now
facing 18 charges including possessing
child pornography and extortion in a
statement janjua's parents say he loved
hockey and loved life and they say as we
grieve the loss of our son we want other
parents to know this could happen to
anyone talk to your kids they say about
Internet safety and keep the door to
Communication open so they can come to
you for help the Finance Minister
Christia Freeland has announced more
money to help renters and low-income
Canadians experiencing
homelessness we need to do what we can
um to be sure that every Canadian has a
roof over their head and warm food to
eat preand announced a $99 million top
up to the Canada housing benefit with
which delivers one-time rental support
payments directly to low-income
Canadians another $100 million will go
to 85 communities across Canada for
emergency winter shelter
spaces there is an update tonight on the
Alaska Airlines Boeing 737 max9 plane
that lost a door plug mid-flight
according to a preliminary report from
the US national Transportation safety
board four bolts used to secure the
panel were removed at a Boeing factory
and it appears they were not replaced
the panel had been opened to repair
damaged rivets on the fuselage of that
Max 9 the report says photo
documentation shows evidence of the door
plug closed with no retention Hardware
in three visible locations that panel
blew off the Boeing plane on January 5th
forcing Pilots to make a harrowing
emergency landing Boeing says it will
review the findings he's waiting to head
all the way up to space coming up I'll
speak with Canadian astronaut Jeremy
Hansen about what he's doing to prepare
for next year's
Mission he is set to make history but
it's going to happen a little later than
first planned astronaut Jeremy Hansen
will be the first Canadian to go on a
mission around the Moon a lunar flyby he
along with three Americans are set to go
on a 10-day test flight on Artemis 2 a
brand new program that aims to
eventually land humans on the moon again
Artemis one an unmanned Mission has
already made the trip traveling
thousands of miles beyond the moon and
back but NASA has now delayed the launch
of Artemis 2 until September of 2025 it
says that will give teams more time to
work through some of the challenges with
me from Ottawa is Jeremy Hansen Jeremy
pleasure to see you again wow nice to
speak with you Donna so this delay is it
a bit frustrating for you that you won't
be going up in November or a little bit
reassuring in terms of making sure that
everything's safe yeah definitely the
latter we it really felt like the right
decision to make we've learned some
things from emis one that we realized we
could have a closer look at now we could
do some more experimentation here on the
ground to make sure we understand some
things like the heat shield for me it
just feels like a really smart decision
sometimes it's hard for leadership to
make those courageous decisions but I
feel very reassured that we've done it
in this case there was an issue with the
heat shields on arous one is that the B
biggest
concern I think that's the one of the
biggest ones there's some other things
that we're working through I wouldn't
say they're big concerns but they're
definitely challenges and I mean this is
what I love I love watching this team
dig into these challenges I see people
in their areas of expertise they're
learning new things uh We've set some
big goals humanity is going back to the
Moon we're doing it with new uh
infrastructure new goals to go back to
the moon for a sustained presence and
eventually Mars and so you have to
expect some challenges along the way and
when you have big challenges like that
you get big results yeah for sure Jeremy
what do you do between now and September
of 2025 I know you have to keep up a
certain level of Fitness you're of
course a physicist an astronaut a
fighter pilot you're an Aquanaut what do
your days look like
now so they're varied it's uh it's
really fun I'm having a great time with
the team but some examples are we're
spending quite a bit of time in the
simulator going through some of the
mission profile working with mission
control for how we will deal with
situations you know should they arise
during the real Mission so that's really
neat to work on that we're doing a lot
of testing of software Ware and systems
we have an upcoming uh full dress
rehearsal for when we land in the
Pacific Ocean after the mission so we'll
be in the capsule and the US Navy will
come and remove us from the capsule put
us in a helicopter take us to a ship
we'll do all of that coming up you will
be busy all right thanks so much for
being with us Canadian astronaut Jeremy
Hansen in Ottawa thanks my
pleasure Fed Up Farmers ahead Spain
joins a growing wave of protests in
Europe
[Music]
Spanish Farmers block traffic on more
than a dozen major highways joining
farmers who are staging similar protests
in other European countries including
France they're demanding action on high
Fuel and energy costs bureaucracy and
competition from non-eu Nations Spain's
government says it will distribute € 269
million euros in Aid to help alleviate
the the impacts from drought and the war
in Ukraine as Russia's war in Ukraine
approaches the 2-year Mark polling
suggests Canadians are increasingly
split over the future of the conflict
ipo's polling done for global news shows
nearly 60% of Canadians surveyed believe
this country is already doing enough to
support Ukraine up from 52% last year
more than half say Canada cannot afford
to give Ukraine more financial aid an
increase of 6% from 2023 as David Aken
explains the numbers show the the
softening support for Ukraine is
especially being felt among conservative
voters all those in favor of the motion
will please rise the governing liberals
were joined by MPS from the NDP and bl
bequa to support a new Canada Ukraine
free trade deal it's a deal Canadian
supporters and the government of Ukraine
say will help strengthen Ukraine's
economic prospects as it continues to
fight off Russian Invaders all those
opposed to the motion but the
conservatives voted against it objecting
to a clause in which Canada and Ukraine
agree to cooperate on carbon pricing and
carbon taxes conservative MPS insist
they stand behind Ukraine despite their
vote against the free trade deal we will
send Ukraine artillery and Rockets not
carbon taxes but the Liberals accus
conservative leader Pierre POV of
betraying Ukraine he is choosing to not
stand with Ukraine not stand with ukra
Ians and not stand with Ukrainian
Canadians why are they abandoning
Ukraine and in fact new polling data
provided exclusively to Global News
shows those who identify as conservative
supporters are much more likely to say
Canada should be pulling back from
Ukraine for example 47% of conservatives
agreed with the statement Canada should
stay out of Ukraine's problems because
Ukraine is not a NATO country and Canada
has no treaty obligation to help only
around 20% of liberal NDP and BQ
supporters agreed with that idea and
when it comes to the idea of Ukraine
negotiating a peace deal with Russia
even while Russian forces still occupy
parts of Ukraine 40% of conservatives
agree with that plan while around 25% of
supporters of other parties agree
polling is one thing doing the right
thing is another thing uh supporting our
allies working with um with other
governments is is is really important no
matter how they answered the other
questions more than half of all
respondents say they continue to closely
follow the news about developments in
Ukraine David Aken Global News
Ottawa former Chilean president
Sebastian Panera has died in a
helicopter crash authorities say the
chopper plunged into a lake in southern
Chile three others on board survived the
74y old billionaire served two terms one
of them during the covid-19 p pandemic
when Chile had one of the highest
vaccination rates in the world Panera
founded a credit card company in the
1970s and was worth an estimated $2.7
billion I have
a next how Toby Keith paved his own path
in country
music Toby Keith the American country
music singer songwriter who is
unapologetically patriotic has died
Keith was 62 years old he'd been
undergoing treatment for stomach cancer
Mike dlay looks at his legacy and why
his music could sometimes be
polarizing
[Music]
many Toby Keith didn't write this song
about himself but when he stood on stage
in 2023 his 6'3 frame gaunt from
fighting stomach cancer there was no
denying why he chose to sing it he was
somebody that wore it on his sleeve and
that's what he was going through and I
can't imagine the gripping battle that
um anyone has with cancer let alone
being in the public eye when that
[Music]
happens when Keith burst onto the
country scene in 1993 he was a breath of
fresh air unlike many other stars he
wrote all his own songs over 5,000 in
his career but when Nashville the
country capital of America beckoned he
stayed home in Oklahoma Nashville wanted
to make him their Golden Boy but he's
not that guy he's not a play by the
rules kind of guy and he's like I just
realized I wasn't going to play their
game I was going to do things my way and
that he certainly did after 9/11 he
released this
song
courtesy which became something of an
Ode to American patriotism all of the
extreme left was hating on it and all
extreme right on on it was using me as a
poster child and when he agreed to sing
at president Donald Trump's inauguration
when so many others refused he was
labeled right-wing despite being a
longtime conservative Democrat throw
politics out he didn't follow a certain
path he just wanted to let you know that
hey I salute my flag and I love this
country and I'm going to scream that
from the mountain tops congratulations
his music sparked both praise and
criticism he was divisive complicated
a country music legend Mike drite Global
News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Tuesday I'm donor freezen tonight's
here at Canada is Mount Aerosmith near
Portell Bernie BC we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to viewers at
Global national.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow
[Music]
bye-bye